all right let's see how this sounds all right already did October 14th 2025
already put that one in and I did Monday so this is gonna be the week is gonna be
October 13th through October 19th and that's a Monday through Sunday week
okay and let's see
on Wednesday October 15th Austin Kelly Mike Walton and Kevin Worley were the
servers and each of them made $241.33 the Busser Slash Expo so he made 5% of
food sales that day was Jamison and that tip-out was calculated as 60 bucks so
so on Thursday August excuse me Thursday October 16th 2025 Austin Kelly and this
is after tip-out for this day only Austin Kelly made $384 after tipping out
Maddox Porter 60 bucks so exactly $60
okay excuse me so now we're at so now we're at the Thursday p.m. shift and
that's how all these are gonna be divided is between a.m. and p.m. shift so
this is Thursday October 16th 2025 and again these are the final numbers so
Austin Kelly Janelle Backey and Janelle Backey is spelled J-A-N-E-L B as in boy
A-K-I and Heather Martin those were the three servers slash bartenders and each
of them made $276.69 Coben and that's Coben cross and that's spelled C-O-B-E-N
and then his last name is cross which is spelled C-R-O-S-S he made $123.54 and
again that's after excuse me so those numbers I gave you for Austin Janelle
and Heather those are all after tip-out
okay and then for Friday October 17th we're tipping out Coben C as in Charlie
O-B as in boy E-N Coben cross and it's a tip pool between Mike and Austin all
these other days I've been tip pools too by the way so they tip pool you know
I'd say 90% of the time and I want to start doing this for all of you know for
a lot more things I want to use this as a way to just kind of like talk and you
know see it reflected through productivity on AI would be sick okay so
again Friday morning the a.m. shift on October 17th 2025 Mike Walton and Austin
Kelly were tip pooling tipping out Coben excuse me Coben Mike had a hundred and
twenty dollars and seven cents in fees or excuse me no he had a hundred and
twenty dollars and seven cents in total tips the tip out to Coben would have
been $22.30 and on this day he was making five percent because he was making five
percent because he was expo and Buster also known as a utility guy so that was
Mike's tips again Coben was getting tipped out but I just gave you Mike's
report now we're moving on to Austin Kelly's report total tips were $95 total
tip out was $19.69 and he and Mike are just going to be splitting that tip out
Friday night the servers were Janelle Austin Kelly and it's Janelle back again
and Mike Walton Janelle did $494.92 in tips her tip out would have been $64.25
to the Buster which is four percent of food and $16.06 to the expo which is one
percent of food for a total of $80.31 I'm not sure who the Buster was on Friday
October 17th for the p.m. shift so I'm gonna have to figure that out but that's
did in tips and what her tip out should have been Austin Kelly's tips $480.58 total excuse
me so the Buster tip out was $35.69 expo was $8.92 for a total of $44.61 Mike Walton's
total tips were $322.99 the tip out so again so these total tips that I'm saying for all these
reports every single one I ever tell you when I'm like the total tips on their report those are all
before tip out so so you know tip out needs to be subtracted from those numbers so you know in this
case his total tips were $322.99 and then we have to you know we would have or we need to subtract
or we need to pull their tip out but what the tip out would be for if they weren't pulling for Mike
in this case to the Buster which is four percent of food would be $43.46 expo which is one percent
of food would be $10.86 for a total of $54.32 for a tip out
uh October 18th Saturday this is the AM shift
uh Coban was the Buster and expo he um and then so look so these tips for the servers
these are going to be after tip out so Janelle $299.98 Mark $299.98 so
uh
so yeah so earlier when I said something about that uh the tips on all the reports
uh so when I read each individual server's tips and then I read their tip out that means that I'm
reading it from their actual like toast report toast rpos and so that means that those need to
be calculated like I need to figure out the the you know total tips after tip out and after pulling
for those days but like for example for this one for October 18th which was Saturday morning
yeah Saturday morning
they wrote a little thing for me so they wrote a note for me and sometimes they'll do that
and so this just is their final thing and I wish they would do this more often but
so we have the final one today Janelle Bakke made $299.98 and Mark also made $299.98
Coban was the Buster he made $111.45
so that one is just on a silver platter um Saturday night
Coban and Maddox um are going to split $131.11
um and then so these again are after tip out
it's Mark Buryanek and Buryanek is spelled B as in boy U-R-Y-A-N-E-K
um Janelle Bakke again B as in boy A-K as in kangaroo I
and Heather Martin
so Mark so each one of those servers there's three of them again would have made $243.70
so now on Sunday October 19th in the morning Kevin
Worley and Mike Walton were the two servers they did not tip pool Coban was the expo slash Buster
um
and Mike's tip out to Coban would have been $17.60 again that's Mike Walton's tip out $17.60 to Coban
Cross and then Kevin Worley
his tip out should have been $31.20
um yeah so Kevin's final tips on this day would have just been $236.98
minus $31.20 and Mike Walton's tips would have been $87.44 minus $17.60 again no tip pool on that day
so I'm going to transcribe this and I'm excited
so this is Sunday night now October 19th 2025 um Coban was the expo and the Buster
um he should have made let's see so for this day Kevin gave me the total or excuse me so after
so after they add up all their tips before tip out so Kevin before tip out made $236.85
again that's $236.85 Mark made $313.70 before tip out so the total there is $550.55
cents that divided by two is $275.27 so we need to calculate each of their tips based on
the total tip out between the two of them to Coban Cross being $79.28 and that's the last one